To get started, I just wanted to
ask you both to introduce yourself.
We are really fortunate today to have
two second year students with us,
Petra Weiss and Mike Ding.
Thank you again for joining us.
Could both of you talk a little
bit about your backgrounds?
How did you come to the GSB?
Why did decide to pursue an MBA and
what were you doing before you came here?
Sure, yeah, so I'll, should I start?
>> Yeah, please.
>> Great.
So I am Petra, for
those of you who didn't know, I'm Petra.
And I worked at Google
before business school.
And while I was there, I realized that I
had this gap in people management skills.
And that was my reason for
wanting to go back to business school.
And so as I was looking at schools I
was trying to find a school
that aligned with that goal.
So one that focused on coaching and
interpersonal dynamics and
really building out those
people management skills.
And as I learned more and
more about the GSB I saw that
that was almost a perfect match.
And so I decided to go to business school
after about three years in the working
world to build out those skills.
And to go back into a management role,
post business school.
>> Great, thank you.
>> Sure.
>> Mike, how about you?
>> Hi, everyone, my name is Mike Ding,
I'm a second year MBA.
Before Stanford,
I worked in private equity and
venture capital investing in
technology companies in San Francisco.
So in terms of coming to business school,
I think one reason why I decided to come.
Is my first job out of college, I actually
had a manager who was a Stanford MBA grad.
The place where I worked was not
the most touchy feely sort of place.
>> [LAUGH]
>> People tended to be very aggressive,
there wasn't a lot of mentorship.
The type of leadership was very different
from what we're taught at the GSB.
One thing that really inspired me,
in my first employer,
was how this guy took a very
active interest in my development.
And he led in a way that was very
motivational, inspiring, very empathetic.
And I just really respected him,
I admired the way that he managed.
And I wanted to learn how to do that
as well, and he actually encouraged me
to apply to the GSB was actually
one of my recommenders as well.
>> Awesome, that's great,
that actually brings up a question
one of you is asking online
about the Alumni Network.
So you worked with someone in
the GSB community pre MBA.
How have you leveraged that network
currently, and that goes for both of you,
whether it's through internships or
general mentorship?
>> Do you want to take it?
>> Sure,
I can talk a little bit about that.
So I have worked at a number of firms
that have been led by GSBers.
The private equity firmed that I worked
at before business school was founded by
a GSBer.
I worked at an investment firm in New York
over the summer that was also founded by
a GSBer.
And in each case,
when I receive an offer from these places,
throughout the process I'd actually
been able to contact these individuals.
Because they were affiliated with the GSB,
because they took an active
interest in students.
Who were interested in the GSB, or
were currently attending the GSB.
And in each case, I think the application
process itself was already
very much helped by the fact that
I was a part of the GSB network.
But even while I was there,
I think because I came from Stanford,
because the founders of these
firms were Stanford grads.
It enabled me to connect with them much
more easily than someone who may not
have had that shared background.
>> Yeah, and building on that,
I think being at the GSB,
I've used the Alumni Network
a huge amount.
So for those you who don't know,
we have a joint degree program
in education and business.
So while I knew I wanted to go
back into people management after.
I wasn't sure exactly whether that
would fall into the education space or
the tech space.
And so I have done probably
about a hundred informational
interviews with folks,
both at the GSB on the staff,
and also alumni who have gone
into all sectors of education, so
edtech, higher ed, and charter schools.
And basically everything, and have used
those informationals to really help
me figure out where I
belonged in those two fields.
And so the alumni have been hugely
helpful in getting me to where I am,
and helping me figure out what's next for
me.
>> Yeah, that is huge, wow.
So you talked a little bit about
doing exploration in the MBA program,
pivoting a little bit from
where you were before.
What was the cost benefit that you
thought about coming into an MBA program?
Was it hard to step out of the workplace?
What were the opportunity
costs that you thought about,
and especially when it came to
maybe family or significant others?
Sure, yeah, I think there were a couple
of big opportunity costs for me.
The first, I would say,
is that my trajectory at Google,
where I was before school,
was looking positive.
So it was really hard for
me to say if I do want to come back and
be a manager in tech,
why am I really taking this time out now?
When it looks like I could get to where
I want to get just by staying at Google.
But a lot of my mentors, and
a lot of actually folks at Google that I
worked with had taken those two years and
sort of reinforced the interpersonal and
coaching skills that you simply can't get,
or invest in the same way
while you're working.
And so, I figured for me,
it was really important to go
back early after three years.
Before that opportunity cost got too high
for me, to restart my career a little bit.
And then again also I think because I
wanted to explore education as well.
It seemed like a good
time to really decide,
do I continue to invest
in the tech space or not?
So it seemed like an opportunity cost but
when I stepped back, didn't feel as much
one where it seemed like going
early would sort of reduce that.
And then I would say the second big thing
is my fiance lives in New York City.
And so that was a big decision,
because I had the opportunity to move with
Google to New York City, and be with him.
Or obviously come to Stanford and
be apart.
And so I think that was
definitely a huge consideration.
But the GSP has a fantastic,
significant other network, and
has really brought him in.
He's actually really good friends
with Mike now through the GSB, so
he's been extremely welcomed
into this community.
And he actually has had lots of interviews
with GSB alums that I've set up for
him through the Alumni Network as well.
I actually, quick story,
emailed about ten people
in real estate in New York City on
his behalf, and all ten replied.
>> Wow.
>> So
just another story about
the power of the Alumni Network.
And yes, it's an opportunity cost,
but I think we'll be stronger for
having had the exposure
we've had while here.
>> That's great, speaking of the exposure
you've had while you're here.
I was wondering if each of you could
talk a little bit about the academic
experience.
Mike, if you want to start with
maybe a favorite class, or
an experience that stands out to you
specifically around the academics?
>> Sure, well as I mentioned before,
one of the reasons why I came to
business school was to really learn
how to be this type of inspirational,
motivational leader that my first
manager was coming out of college.
And I think the GSP does an incredible
job of giving you real life experience.
Quote unquote, real life, but experiential
learning opportunities to do that.
One class that I will remember
as the most impactful class that
I had was interpersonal dynamics,
also known as touchy feely.
Which is a class where you really explore
kind of how you react to other people.
But also how you come off to other people.
And I would say,
before the GSB, I was always
very afraid to truly open up
to people about how I felt,
how they made me feel, what my impact was
on them, what their impact was on me.
But this is a sort of class
that creates a safe space for
people to really ask those
tough questions of each other.
And, give each other honest
feedback about those impacts.
And so, I would say that
the experiential learning,
especially through classes
like Touchy Feely,
has been the just most amazing part
of the academic curriculum here.
>> Wow.
Patrick, could you expand
a little bit on that?
What proportion would you say of
classes kind of break down different
teaching styles?
How much time would you spend
on cases versus lectures,
versus experiential learning?
>> Sure.
>> And a little bit more on the tactical
side, is it hard to get electives, or
do you get to take
the classes that you want?
>> Sure.
Yeah, so I would say first year was
more lecture and case based for me.
And feel free to jump in if you disagree.
But first year it was
probably about half and half.
So for some of my classes like Strategy,
we were in a case based format.
For others, like Accounting,
it was a little bit more lecture based,
although there were some
cases that were done.
And so the professors basically
decided what would be the best way for
folks to learn the material that we're
teaching and the most effective way.
So that was mostly about half and half.
For the elective second year, a lot
more of them have been experiential for
me because again,
I have been focusing on coaching, and
interpersonal dynamics, and
part of a program called Aruckle Fellows.
And so that shift second year has
been mostly to experiential and
then still some lecture and
case base mixed in, but probably about 60%
experiential and
the rest case and lecture based.
>> Okay, great, so
you mentioned Arbuckle Leadership Fellows.
Maybe you can talk a little
bit about what that is, and
then both of you can also add on
other extracurriculars that you're
involved with, and other commitments that
you have outside of coursework and school.
And also, how much time you actually
do spend on homework and classes,
relative to that.
>> Sure.
Yeah so, Arbuckle Fellows is
a coaching program that was started,
I want to say about ten years now, but I'm
not exactly sure if that's the right date.
And basically it allows the second
year class to coach and
lead the first years through
what we call Leadership Labs,
which is a first year required
class in your first quarter.
That allows you to think about what
kind of leader you want to be if
you're the kind of leader you aren't,
how do you get there?
Learning from other leadership styles
that other students have that you
can sort of learn from.
So you as an Arbuckle Fellow, lead six
students in that first quarter class and
then you switch into one on one
coaching for the winter term.
And so you actually get assigned three
coachees that you work with each week for
an hour,
working through all sorts of topics.
So it ranges from leadership topics to
how do I balance my life at the GSB,
academics, and social, and career to
just personal stuff that's going on.
So.
>> Okay.
>> That's been my most fulfilling
activity at the GSB.
A huge chunk of time.
>> Yeah.
>> But a really great way to
practice those leadership and
coaching skills that I
came here to work on.
>> Awesome.
Mike, how do you spend your
time outside of class?
Are there particular clubs that
you're really involved with?
>> Yeah, yeah I can talk to that.
So I spent a lot of my time
actually helping TA classes.
>> Mm-hm.
>> At the GSB,
especially in the second year.
>> Interesting, yeah.
>> And, it's actually one of
the things that I've personally found,
kind of most rewarding about the Stanford
experience, which is that so
much of the learning that happens here,
happens because we have
just incredible classmates who come
from all types of different backgrounds.
And so because I have a finance,
investing background,
I've spent a lot of my time,this
year helping two of the finance
professors here teach classes,
TA classes, develop case material.
And that's sort of been my bug commitment
outside of regular coursework.
And it's something that I do because,
I think, one, it's good practice
in terms of learning how to be a leader,
how to communicate, how to teach people.
But at the same time it's allowed me
to give back to the community that
I think has already given me
a lot over the past two years.
In terms of the split between time
spent on different activities,
I would say it varies pretty dramatically,
so
it's very hard to say what the average is,
because it's very unrepresentative
of the variants is very large.
And so I would say that
the great thing about the GSB,
is that If you come there is no
structure to which you have to adhere.
>> Mm hm.
>> If you want to spend a lot
of time on academics and
I feel like I've probably indexed on that
relatively more heavily than some of
are classmates, then you can do that.
If you want to spend more of
your time on extra curriculars,
more of your time on
even social activities,
that's completely accepted and
even encouraged at Stanford.
I think it's really hard to say what
a typical GSB student looks like,
because there is no typical GSB student.
Like everyone has different priorities and
all those priorities
are welcomed by the community.
>> Yeah, choose your own adventure.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> So
we talked about learning in the classroom.
Could each of talk about one of the global
experiences or maybe multiple that you've
been involved with and
how that's shaped your GSB experience?
>> Sure.
Yeah, so I participated in a GST, so a
Global Study Trip to Thailand last winter.
And so the global study trips
are led by second years.
I was a first year at the time, so we were
taken to Thailand by five second years
who totally crafted the experience and
chose to look at the country through food.
So we studied the food
supply chain in Thailand,
we visited a local rice patty, but we
also went and visited some of the largest
conglomerates that are actually packaging
and distributing all over the world.
And so, we just had a chance
to explore a new culture,
meet with all sorts of people.
Again, from someone running their own
small shop to someone running a huge
conglomerate.
And we're able to do it together.
So it was definitely for me,
I thought It allowed me to see
the country in a whole new way,
because we were very on the ground and
seeing it from all these different angles.
But also it really allowed me to forge
incredible friendships through just by
being a country in a totally
new place with folks that
I didn't know super well before the trip.
And so I think I left with a whole new
appreciation for the country of Thailand,
but also for a lot of my classmates who
I may not have otherwise gotten to know.
Okay.
>> Yeah, I had a similar experience.
The trip that I remember most
vividly is actually one that was
organized by our classmates to India.
And we spent about ten days there,
met with everyone ranging from political
leaders to small business owners.
To executives at larger corporations,
and learned a lot about India.
And developed a new sense of appreciation
for the amount of growth and
potential in the country.
I think that stuff is,
you can get that stuff
just by going to different countries and
traveling on your own.
What's really unique about the trips that
you take at the GSB to these countries,
is that you're going with classmates.
I think something like 40% of our
class is international students.
And so, in all of these countries,
the people who are leading you,
the people who are showing you
the country, are people from those places.
Who either grew up there,
went to school there, or worked there.
And have incredible networks, and
just an incredible depth of
understanding of those places.
I think that's what's really
unique about these trips.
It's not the fact that you
can go all over the world,
it's the fact that you can go with someone
who knows those places intimately.
That's been the most meaningful part
of the interactional experience for
me at the GSB.
>> Yeah, our trip leader to Thailand
actually was from Thailand.
And so we had big family dinners with
her family who all live over there.
And got to meet leaders who we would
not otherwise have had access to.
So I think that's really a good point
about seeing the country through someone's
eyes who's actually
experienced it day to day.
>> Yeah, great, so some of the exploration
happens through global experiences.
I think a lot of self exploration
also happens at the GSB.
And when you think about exploring your
career opportunities, have you used
any specific resources at Stanford to
help you navigate that exploration?
I know you mentioned possibly
doing a career change.
So how has that been influenced by the GSB
and opportunities through the MBA program?
>> Yeah, I would say for me, it was mostly
those informational interviews that had
shaped that, and again,
access to the Alumni Network.
Also, we have a fantastic career center.
So, I basically took those informational
interviews, had two buckets
that I wanted to focus on for
my summer internship and for longer term.
And the career center pulled up a whole
nother list of alums in those spaces,
helped me think through a timeline.
To actually think about trying
different things during the year.
And I'm actually doing an internship, so
as I mentioned I'm a joint degree
student in ed and in business.
And I'm actually doing an internship
with Stanford undergrads through
the reslife department to fully
explore that higher ed opportunity.
So that's possible,
you get course credits through the GSB.
So I'm actually getting credit for
that internship.
And so you don't just have the summer
experience to explore this career change,
but you also have time
throughout the year.
I have classmates who
have started companies.
I have classmates who have done 390s,
what we call 390s similar to
this experience with res ed.
And because we have
access to Silicon Valley,
a lot of folks are pitching VC's and
working there day to day.
So I think those both,
the Alumni Network, the Career Center and
this internship day to day
have really helped me.
Solidify how to make that change, and
whether I want to make that change.
>> Okay, you touched on something
that we also have a question about,
which is GSB location.
And Mike, I don't know if this has
come into your thought process for
recruiting, or
the more formal channels of the GSB.
Have you gotten a sense of how our
location in Silicon Valley has either
expanded opportunities.
Or the challenges that might come
with being on the west coast?
>> So I have a personal bias
towards the west coast,
I've been here for-
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Almost ten years, and so
that was actually a huge selling point for
me.
For those of you who may not have been
here, the weather here is pretty awesome.
I would say that certainly
if you're in Palo Alto,
but your desired industry and
company and firms are in New York City.
There's no question that that
becomes logistically more difficult.
Flying six hours out to New York,
flying back, is more challenging than
for students at some of our
peer schools on the east coast.
That doesn't mean however, that those
firms aren't interested in GSB graduates.
In fact, a lot of the demand,
a lot of the job opportunities available
through the CMC,
are from New York employers.
And so the down side to
the geography is not limited access,
it's actually just logistical difficulty.
And that's something I found when
I was interviewing in New York.
I was interviewing with
some investment firms.
And just flying out there was
the most painful part, but
it wasn't hard to get them to
be interested in GSB grads.
Obviously the benefit is
if you're interested in
industries that are more
centered around the Bay Area.
Biotech, information technology,
obviously, then there is, I think,
the access and the logistical
ease is pretty unparalleled.
So, it really depends on what you want.
But, I guess what I would emphasize,
is that access is incredibly broad.
And that the one committment
you'd have to make
is to undergo some more logistical
challenges in flying back and forth.
>> Yeah, and building off that, I think,
I did recruit on the east coast full time.
And I think two things that actually
helped in being out here, surprisingly.
One is that we have really long breaks.
So I would use those breaks to
network with folks in New York.
And really set up informational interviews
and interviews during those periods.
And you do have, yes, logistical
nightmares during the school year.
But if you're really strategic and
smart about how you use your time off.
Stanford gives you a ton of time off
to be able to fly to other places.
And then the second thing is,
recruiters are, I think, a little bit
more surprised to get emails from folks
on the west coast about east coast jobs.
And jobs in Chicago, and
jobs in Texas, and things like that.
So I think you actually have, or
I found that I actually had somewhat of
an advantage, because they're like,
why would you want to leave California?
[LAUGH] And so I found myself actually
recruiting with a smaller pool of people.
And so I think yes, you do have the access
if you want to stay in California.
But if you don't, I think
the availability of breaks to network,
and then also the fact that most people
do choose to stay in California.
You have your bit of an anomaly,
you actually have some increased
opportunity as a result.
>> And I think also the size
of our program relatively,
compared to the number of
opportunities on the east coast.
It's just a supply and
demand perspective there's so
few people I think relativly
in the larger scheme.
That it creates a supply demand
advantage for our student body.
And you brought up a really good example,
even with your significant other working
in real estate in New York
having access to our alums.
So I also think about networks
more broadly than geography.
I think a lot about networks in
2016 being informational networks,
and access to people who
really have deep expertise.
And I think so much of that,
of course you want contextual knowledge,
but also learning about The access
to information that you have through
our alums can really cross borders and
time zones pretty easily these days.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> So, while logistics can be a challenge,
we also have a question about
challenges in general at Stanford.
And someone's asking us,
what has been your most difficult
experience at Stanford?
It's a head scratcher.
>> Sure.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I can tell you about mine.
So, I'm actually at Stanford with my
partner and we applied at the same time.
We were both really
fortunate to be admitted.
And she's also an MBA too.
And the biggest challenge for us just on a
personal level was just in the beginning,
the GSB is so all consuming in terms of
its demands on your time from
the academics to the social scene.
To, you're thinking about jobs and
internships and
should I start a business etc., etc.
And I think the biggest challenge for
us and a source of friction in our
relationship in those early days coming
to GSB was how much time do we spend
on spending time with each other versus
on these other priorities that we have?
Because we do want to go through the
transformative experience that the GSB has
to offer.
And I think it generalizes
to a broader point, for
me, it manifested itself in my
relationship with my significant other.
I think for people who don't have
partners here, the generalization is that
you have your personal life, you have your
life that you led before the GSB and now
you have these massive time commitments
that are put on you by the GSB.
And the question of how you balance those
two can be fraught with uncertainty,
and can cause frictions with
your relationships with people,
before you came.
I think everyone I know has successfully
worked through those, my partner and
I, we're able to find the right balance,
but
in the beginning that can
be a really big challenge.
>> Yeah, and
just building off of that I think,
I think my biggest challenge was
the transition fall quarter as well.
For slightly different reasons, I think I
came in knowing what I wanted to focus on.
But the second you get here,
you're exposed to so much and
you're exposed to so
many different classmates.
And you hear about a company that
someone's been at and you're like, wow,
that sounds interesting, maybe I'll
add a third industry to look at.
And so I think, for me,
it was really figuring out,
how do I learn to say no to things, and
be comfortable getting out of the
experience what I came here to get out?
And so I would say the more clear you
can be about what you want from business
school, and the closer you can
stick to that when you're here,
the easier that adjustment is.
But I would say, yeah,
that the first quarter at the GSB,
there's a lot going on and there's a lot
of opportunity, it's really critical
to focus on what you decide that you
want to get out of the experience.
>> Yeah, that's perfect, I really
appreciate you adding some advice in
there, because I was going to ask if you
had any final tips, so that's really great
words to live by, not just for
the application, but I think for life.
Mike, any final thoughts on tips
coming into either applying to or
attending the GSB?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
So my final word of advice for the guests
who are watching over the internet,
is that a lot of the admissions process,
and even the GSB process itself,
if you haven't been a part of it,
if you haven't experienced it yet,
it can seem contrived.
It can seem like, what do they actually
mean by being introspective and
being reflective?
Aren't those just buzz-words, right?
>> Right, yeah.
>> And what I would say is,
they can be, and they can be,
that only happens if you
don't truly kind of buy in.
If you don't truly commit yourself
to being reflective, right?
To thinking about why have you
made the decisions you did?
Being honest about that.
Being honest about where you're from,
who you are, what your goals are,
instead of what you think that society or
admissions officers want to see from you.
Or, if you're admitted,
what you think your peers or
your professors want to see from you.
The only way you really get
to experience the GSB's
benefits at a true level of depth is
when you buy in, is when you say, I
am going to do these things even though it
feels kind of awkward and cheesy at first.
I am going to reflect, I am going to
think about my life as it's been so
far, and what I hope for
it to be like in the future.
So that would be my final word of advice,
and the buzzword I would use to
capture that is be authentic.
Be authentic to yourself.
>> Those are great tips, both for
the application and for life.
I wanted to thank you both so
much for taking the time.
I know you always have 50 things you
could be doing any half hour of the day.
So I really appreciate it and
you really brought the GSB to life.
So, thank you so much.
All of you that are joining us,
I want to thank you for your time as well.
Really appreciate you taking the time
to learn more about the MBA program.
As a reminder you can always learn
more about the GSB on our website,
and we'll also be on the road this summer.
So if you want to learn more
about Stanford in person,
you can take a look at our
event calendar online.